there is a lot of water on Mars and
there once was a lot of surface flowing
water you don't you don't see it because
it's most of it is mixed with the soil
which we call regolith on Mars so the
Martian soil can be anywhere from as
little as 1% in some very dry desert II
like areas - as much as 60% water one
strategy for getting water when you're
on Mars is to break up the regolith
which would take something like a
jackhammer because it's very cold it's
very frozen if you can imagine making a
frozen brick or a chunk of ice that's
mostly soil and maybe half water and a
half soil that's what you would be
dealing with so you need to break this
up put it in an oven as it heats up it
turns to steam you're running through a
distillation tube and you have pure
drinking water comes out the other end
there is a much easier way to get water
on Mars in this country we have
developed industrial dehumidifiers and
there's a and they they're very simple
machines that simply blow the air in a
room or a building across a mineral
called zeolite zeolite is very common on
earth it's very common on Mars and
zeolite is kind of like a sponge it
absorbs water like crazy takes the
humidity right out of the air then you
squeeze it and out comes the water and
scientists working for NASA at the
University of Washington as long ago as
90 in the night at late 1990s developed
a machine called wave R that very
efficiently sucks water out of the
Martian atmosphere so water is not
nearly the significant problem it
appears to be we also know from orbiters
around Mars and right now there are five
satellites orbiting Mars we know from
photographs that these orbiters have
taken and geological studies that
they've done that there is frozen ice on
the surface of Mars now there's tons of
it at the poles some of it is over laden
with frozen or mixed with frozen carb
dioxide but in many craters on Mars
there apparently are sheets of frozen
water
so if early astronauts or early voyagers
to Mars were to land near one of those
sheets of ice in a crater they would
have all the water they need
you